y en nuestro tema del día vamos a hablar
de la conferencia de la onu sobre el
clima la cob 26 que se desarrolla en
glasgow en escocia se espera que tras
los o mal implementados acuerdos de
parís de 2015 en esta edición los
líderes mundiales activistas por el
clima y también expertos lleguen a
acuerdos tangibles para poder frenar el
calentamiento global y reducir las
emisiones de carbono para ello quiero
saludar a mis dos invitados de estas
horas la primera es elisa giraldo que
está conmigo aquí en el estudio
directora de logística y alianzas
estratégicas de la l coi de colombia y
parte del pacto por el clima lisa
gracias por estar aquí con nosotros en
directo américa de france 24 y también
quiero saludar en este segundo invitado
les roberto trotta vicepresidente
director regional para américa latina
por
www v efe roberto también gracias por
estar con nosotros en directo américa en
france 24 elisa le quiero empezar
preguntando que podemos ver en esta con
26 que ustedes como jóvenes por el clima
ya han hecho no para que estos líderes
mundiales en esta cumbre si digamos de
alguna manera se pongan las pilas y
empiezan a trabajar por el clima y hagan
las acciones que necesitamos ya para
evitar este calentamiento global que
todos los días aumentan
bueno y en primera instancia muchas
gracias por tenerme aquí
yo creo que esto que me pregunta se
divide en varias partes primero podemos
ver una movilización gigante de jóvenes
alrededor del mundo alrededor de la
crisis climática no entonces empieza
como un movimiento que se entiende como
transnacional digamos todo este
movimiento de gritan tornberg de fraudes
por twitter o viernes por el futuro
pero va trascendiendo no y se vuelve un
movimiento latinoamericano un movimiento
asiático un movimiento dividido en
muchas regiones del mundo que ya no se
puede definir únicamente por este por
este eurocentrismo en la acción
climática entonces se vuelve variado se
vuelve dividido y se vuelve local para
que hayan acciones locales
esto por un lado y de otra manera pues
yo destacaría la labor que han hecho
muchos jóvenes alrededor del mundo
generando espacios de acción digamos se
tiene la coi la que es la conferencia
global de la juventud que es un espacio
donde los jóvenes de todo el mundo se
reúnen para generar esta acción
necesaria y esta incidencia y ellos dan
insumos a la cob y este es un espacio
que no se ha ganado en vano esto es un
espacio que se genera porque la mitad de
la población mundial somos los jóvenes y
somos los más afectados por esta crisis
climática entonces
en este sentido generamos como espacios
en donde se genere como
una participación necesaria para
entender los problemas de manera
integral
nosotros como el eco y también nosotros
alimentamos estos procesos
internacionales entonces se entiende
también las problemáticas regionales
como diferenciadas se empieza a generar
una voz juvenil que dice no es que no
somos todos iguales es que nos vemos
todos jóvenes porque como decía la
compañera antes no estamos en el mismo
barco no siempre estamos en el mismo
barco y tenemos condiciones muy
distintas y queremos todos tener una voz
y también pues se genera en milán
recientemente youtuber clay mensual que
es este espacio juvenil donde los
jóvenes generan un manifiesto donde
dicen queremos participación queremos
estar al tanto de lo que está pasando
queremos derechos de acceso a la
información queremos que haya una acción
que sí sea fructífera más que todo
fructífera porque se habla de los
compromisos adquiridos y se habla de las
políticas prevalentes y las políticas
prevalentes tienen una brecha gigante
frente a lo que se promete que se va a
hacer entonces
la ambición es de que justamente esta
brecha entre ambas cosas de cierre bueno
elisa vamos entonces a seguir la
conversación con este segundo invitado
del día ya lo tenemos en nuestro monitor
roberto muy buen día le pregunto qué
podemos esperar entonces de esta 26
vamos a ver acciones concretas o estamos
en un ambiente de pesimismo sin mucho
cambio ya luego de cinco años después de
los acuerdos de parís
bueno muchas gracias y un saludo
especial a elisa y a través de ella a
todos los jóvenes que están realizando
un trabajo importantísimo de
concientización de presencia de
movimiento y tal vez resta destacar que
ese es uno de los temas más importantes
que han generado los últimos cinco años
en la apropiación de espacios la
presencia mucho más
específica directa de distintos grupos
de distintos actores no solamente los
negociadores que estamos viendo aquí en
la pantalla y los decisores políticos a
nivel de gobiernos pero también los
actores locales los gobiernos
subnacionales
los
de roberto lo interrumpo un momento como
usted lo decía tenemos las imágenes en
vivo de esta esta conferencia ya inició
entonces vamos a ver un poco el ambiente
lo que está ocurriendo y seguimos
analizando esta cumbre con 26 roberto yo
hablo con usted
[Música]
bueno ya estamos viendo parte entonces
lo que es esta inauguración en glasgow
en escocia de la cob 26 con un toque
escocesa y estábamos escuchando una
gaita interpretada por una joven no pues
en el marco de esta reunión de la cumbre
de la onu sobre el clima y también
veíamos a los líderes internacionales ya
sentados y como lo habíamos comentado
anteriormente que estábamos conversando
con roberto vamos a estar interrumpiendo
esta conversación para ir con estos
discursos de los líderes para saber que
se está hablando también esta cumbre y
puedes ir analizando y conversando tanto
con roberto como con elisa que también
ya conversábamos o con ella al inicio de
nuestro sección del invitado del día
para hablar esta 26 roberto entonces
vuelvo con ustedes mientras ya esperamos
alguno de los discursos esperamos son
más acción de esta
26 entonces nos quedamos en el punto de
que podemos esperar si realmente se van
a tomar ya las acciones necesarias
porque estamos contrarreloj
y el primer ministro británico boris
johnson antes del inicio de esta cumbre
decía que estamos a un minuto la
medianoche no como en modo de alerta
modo llamado atención y se ve ya como un
cambio también de discurso del primer
ministro boris johnson escéptico no hace
un año atrás dos años atrás con esto el
cambio climático y ya pues se estaba
tomando otro discurso político político
otra tónica ya en tomar acciones para
este cambio climático
roberto es un compromiso un compromiso
global pero como dijo elisa diferenciado
cada quien tiene algo distinto que hacer
pero todos estamos en este barco
recordemos el acuerdo de parís es el
compromiso más emblemático que el mundo
ha asumido para afrontar la amenaza del
cambio climático y recordemos también
que el principal objetivo es limitar el
aumento de la temperatura global a dos
grados centígrados para finales del
siglo y si es posible ese es uno de los
temas claves en esta cumbre en esta
conferencia de las partes del convenio
de cambio climático es limitarlo 1.5
grados centígrados
y para eso los países del mundo se han
comprometido a través de las denominadas
contribuciones determinadas a nivel
nacional a las distintas acciones pero
aquí viene el truco aún si es que todos
estos compromisos de todas las naciones
del mundo se pudieran cumplir al ciento
por ciento estamos con un hueco con un
desfase del 16 por ciento eso quiere
decir que tenemos que aumentar el nivel
de admisión según las naciones unidas
143 países de los 192
firmantes que hacen el acuerdo de países
han presentado estos compromisos y
todavía hay metas que tienen que ser
ajustadas y todavía te tiene que medirse
el impacto de cómo estas contribuciones
que están haciendo los países van a
llegar nos llevarnos a una economía que
cero
neutral neutralmente cero en carbón
y para esto también hay que pensar y hay
que acordarse que este ha sido un
proceso parís fue hace cinco años en los
últimos cinco años y el panel
intergubernamental ha determinado todos
los científicos del mundo han
determinado pues que la situación se va
agudizando y esto es curioso lo podemos
ver en la ventana lo podemos ver
nosotros mismo en estas áreas en donde
antes llovía ahora están secas y
viceversa que los desiertos ahora están
lloviendo los ciclos en que los en los
que los agricultores plantaban o
cosechaban se han alterado y por lo
tanto la cadena de suministros por
ejemplo de nuestra la seguridad
alimentaria está sufriendo la provisión
de agua recordemos ciudades como bogotá
o quito recién en el agua de nuestros
páramos esos páramos se están secando
que es lo que debemos hacer todos todos
tenemos un rol fundamental en esto que
es la cob está empezando a señalar como
la urgencia planetaria mundial pues
roberto vengo con elisa aquí en estudio
en la ciudad de bogotá elisa le quiero
preguntar un poco de la conversación de
la conversación con roberto del mencionó
los acuerdos de parís del año 2015
ustedes como jóvenes que tanto han visto
que se han cambiado las cosas desde 2015
hasta ahora
bueno en este sentido yo creo que han
habido muchos cambios principalmente
para la participación juvenil creo que
cada vez hemos ido tomando más espacios
incluso la sociedad civil la sociedad
civil ha tomado un mayor rol en la
participación se ha vuelto en un espacio
que no solamente se extiende a las
delegaciones a las personas que tienen
el beneficio de asistir un evento como
estos sino que cada vez más la población
se está informando de lo que está
pasando y a partir de esto puede tomar
decisiones más acertadas
en cuanto a los cambios tangibles que ha
habido en las emisiones de dióxido de
carbono
me atrevería a decir de que en teoría en
teoría ha habido una reducción pero esta
reducción nunca sopesar a las emisiones
que se están dando